this video was made possible by honker
impact third thank you for signing up to
our tour at the modern zoo of anime fans
here you will be able to learn and
observe different breeds of the species
known as the anime fan please do not
attempt to feed any anime fan you see as
they live on a very strict diet of food
water and trash EE Sakai pal fantasy
shows there's been lots of research of
the type of anime fans that exists but
documentation of modern fans are less
common as many well-known ones are now
actually endangered or extinct these
include the commonly known casual
weeaboo and elitist
these primitive forms have now evolved
into many different breeds
for example neither the anime plague has
become far more widely spread and
accepted it is harder to classify who is
actually a casual anime fan and who is
just a normal healthy human thus we
present the new classification model for
the modern anime fan we start with the
life stylist the life stylist has taken
over as the modern image of anime fans
and takes a more business casual
approach towards anime many of these are
ex weeaboos or @ are COO that have now
grown up and found this awful new thing
called a life well they may have had
countless hours to sing into anime when
they are young they may find these
slight noises have cropped up like
colleges or working to pay rent and try
not to starve to death or god forbid a
girlfriend that means they have far less
time for animes so they need to optimize
it this means mostly watching things
they hear being discussed by friends or
if they're really desperate might even
resort to watching youtubers to give
them recommendations they are however
still very knowledgeable about anime in
its culture so may end up spending more
time discussing anime in person or
online than actually watching it at rate
also reminiscent of the Mima it is
argued whether a meme of really counts
as an anime fan or not because there has
yet to be a recorded sighting of the
species actually watching anime not
including hentai of course however you
can find them in pretty much every facet
of the anime community as it is
theorized they are able to completely
keep up to date with Adam a entirely
through memes absorbing the surrounding
memes for information in a process
called oz meme sis they are pretty easy
to recognize as they have developed a
unique language of communication through
gifts shitposts and smug anime girls
though the fully mature of the species
can be spotty there pretty much every
convention wearing the [ __ ] eye
hugger
it is unclear where the species normally
resides in the real world but rumors
suggest that many of them are currently
looking to buy property on our / ana
memes this brings us to the collectors
the collectors have spent way too much
money on anime and they themselves
cannot remember how they got in this
position in life nor how to stop it
they are the Pokemon trainers of this
world except instead of catching Pokemon
they catch waifu's under no
circumstances should any of them be
allowed within a ten-mile perimeter of
any device that can play gotcha games
and it is documented that they would
even probably invest in cryptocurrency
if it gave them a chance to get their
waifu despite their spending habits they
never plan to spend money it just kind
of happens once they think they reach a
period of financial stability when they
no longer feel the urge to spend as when
there is a perfectly timed summer event
announcement with new limited edition
swimsuit version y fuse and the next
thing they know they are googling how to
sell their left kidney on the black
market to make more money it is the
common misconception that collectors
have a lot of disposable income when in
fact all they may possess a lot of is a
lack of budgeting skills if we break
down a standard monthly budget and show
to a collector $200 in food $700 in rent
$150 in utilities $1500 on anime
figurines and $2,000 on rerolls in fate
gran order they will look at this and
wonder to themselves
Wow am I really spending that much money
on food and on that no I think it's a
perfect time to introduce the sponsor
for today's educational video honk i
impact third honk I impact is it off of
godsakes of course you'd be here honk I
impact is a free to play action mobile
game yes these graphics and gameplay you
are seeing right now are really running
on my phone and it is running smoothly
as well well starts as an action game
with a simple attack dodge system
quickly increases in depth when your
lock more abilities combos different
characters training abilities with
different characters while parrying
dodging and air juggling and it evolves
into an incredibly satisfying real-time
combat system that will have you hooked
you have a wide array of different
wifey's to unlock with their own unique
fighting style with customisable weapons
and abilities to suit your playstyle as
you play through the existing story mode
or even use the coop features the game
is constantly being updated with the
most recent addition being the dorm
feature build a nice little house for
your girls to rest in where they can
train up in their spare time and
generally just look absolutely adorable
no no no these aren't yours go get your
own go get your up this sounds like your
cup of tea or if you just want to try it
out to any width and click on the link
below to download it on either I
or Android and with that we can go back
to our tour moving on next we have the
hype beast the hype piece has one goal
in life to get hype ever since
experiencing that first spine-tingling
goosebump inducing feeling they live
their life chasing that next high and
we'll watch every anime fight sports
anime and studio trigger show hoping to
be able to reach that same high they
once felt understandably they are mostly
rooted in the shown in genre and while
they argue that the genre has become
more respected critically to enjoy for
older ages this is just so they can hide
the fact that they are all secretly man
children nursing they're in a sugar high
twelve-year-old where everything was
naturally hype similarly to high beasts
we have cancers cancers only care about
one thing
cute anime girls and every one of them
is equipped with a built-in navigation
system that will cause them to gravitate
towards the nearest source of mao-a
unlike the rest of the community arguing
over waifu's and best girls cancers only
believe in spreading love and acceptance
for every girl every girl is deserving
of love because every girl is Maui and
if the answer is Maui there can be no
wrong answer unless the answer is Nico
studies of Shonna this overexposure to
Maui has deteriorated the average
specimen brain into a mindless mushy
goop effects of which can be seen when
they gather in one place dividing
uncontrollably to form a massive
unwanted lump that spreads infecting the
surrounding area with fan boy roars of
Maui love hence the term cancer public
sightings are rare so many assume they
are shut-ins who do not exercise in
truth they are merely hibernating
conserving their energy to the next idol
concert where they are able to release
all limiters doing a workout that breaks
all known laws of physical human
exertion within the space of a single
aqua song and then we get to the
intellectual evolved from the now
endangered ëletís the intellectual is on
a journey to prove anime should be a
deeply respected medium through nuanced
analysis and critical discourse but deep
down they know they are just looking for
a way to justify the countless hours
they have sunk into watching anime with
no tangible achievement or merit to show
for it
the biggest difference between them and
all school elitists is that in this day
and age anime is such a wide medium so
there is no longer widely accepted
zweite taste in anime and it is more
about being able to provide a deeper
well-informed justifications for one's
taste however while many intellectuals
may seek to enlighten the uninformed
casual some may use
newfound powers to put themselves up on
a pedestal perhaps they'll still an
ironically judge people by the number of
entries on there my anime list like it's
still 2008 proving that while there is
no right taste in anime anymore there is
still definitely a wrong one though a
close cousin to the intellectual we have
the animation Taku a new species that
has risen very recently within the anime
fandom
the animation Taku is a black hole for
any and all knowledge about anime
production they can tell you the coffee
girl who is working during production on
the certain episode of anime and follows
approximately 7,000 different animators
on Twitter while they still technically
enjoy anime the anime itself isn't a
significant factor when compared to the
knowledge of the staff members who
worked on it though they will still
experience a single involuntary orgasm
at the site of any impact frames an easy
way to distinguish them is by the
uncontrollable response of disgust when
someone mentions they know about anime
production because they watched Shiro
Barco next up we have the manga reader
these are a mysterious species as we
know they exist but they only really
surfaced the moment an anime is
announced then they all come out of the
rocks and proclaim that they've been
looking forward to this adaptation for
forever only for the rest of the enemy
community to wonder where the [ __ ]
they've been this entire time
a true manga reader doesn't have time
for anime and has realized that reading
manga is a far more efficient way to
consume as much of it as possible what
makes them hard to distinguish is that
they may look act and talk like anime
fans however in reality they would just
watch one episode of an anime where they
have read the source material and then
pretend to everyone like they actually
watch the whole damn thing that's right
margaritas we know next we get to the
fujiyoshi and
[Music]
Kujo she's are obsessed with men though
have probably never interacted with one
in their lifetime studies have shown
they gain their lifeblood by shipping
any two males who are within a 10 meter
radius of each other
failure to observe any and all ships for
an extended period of time will cause
them to dissolve into a messy group of
gay porn it is said that every female
fan possesses a dormant Fujio gene even
if they haven't activated it to become a
full-blown fujiyoshi
the early effects of this gene can be
seen when females grow an unhealthy
addiction to mystic messenger finding
out the heart skipped a beat seeing
gifts of beautiful Asian boys almost
kissing and fully completing their
activation when they can sing the first
verse of unravel by heart last but not
least we have the cosplayer these are
the breeds which have the largest
exposure through pictures that have been
spread online though it is not commonly
known that after a photoshoot is
finished they will disintegrate - back
into their natural form of a pile of
bobby pins and fabric tape while most
humans live by a standard 7 day
Gregorian calendar cosplays but instead
track their time in relation to how many
days they have left until the next anime
convention and thus exist in a perpetual
state of panic trying to figure out how
they're gonna complete their next
costume in time
recently cosplaying has evolved from
just a side hobby to something people
can actually do for their full-time job
if you're a girl then all you need to do
is grow a small bird dedicated following
and you may be able to turn this into
your full-time profession through a
combination of patreon streaming and
selling prints and if you're a guy then
all you need to do is yeah alright good
luck with that mate this concludes our
tour of the modern zoo of anime fans
remember the anime craze has spread far
further than we all imagined and
knowledge is key to stopping this plague
if you suspect that anyone amongst you
may watch anime please inform your
nearest police officer immediately so
they can be quarantined and destroyed
before they are able to contaminate
anyone with their [ __ ] taste
have a lovely day hey guys so if you
enjoyed that video thank you again to
honk I in fact thought for sponsoring
this video if you want to give that a
shot just click the link in the
dooblydoo and they'll bring you to
whatever store your device is on and
also thank you very much to robert
Eyeborg
basil patrick Madison Larkin and ayran
else on patreon for helping to support
me for this month I'm making
video impossible I see a lot of you have
been posting me pictures of your
[ __ ] team others which have now
been placing out so hopefully you guys
are you enjoying your tea or coffee in
these mugs and also you can watch on my
other videos I'll follow me on Twitter
or Instagram for some my other
shenanigans but aside from that until my
next video
I've been gigging and I will see you all
next time